the jurgen experience did you
did you see cosby at all before he won
up going to jail did you ever see him
live no i never saw him live i mean i
saw him live once
when i worked at great white i was
actually working as a security guard
when he was there live
uh but i didn't get to see i wasn't a
comic back then i was 19.
i didn't get to see the whole show or i
really paid attention to it but
he never worked out he and he talked
about it he said i i know what's funny i
know how to
how to do funny like i don't need to
work out my material so he would just
kind of
write and then he would go up and do
these
and from all accounts like chris rock
said it and burr
said it they went to see him they said
it was [ __ ] brilliant brilliant
yeah and he didn't work out like i would
i would like to see what that was like
i would like to see it too yeah jerry
seinfeld chris rock they always said
they went to see
bill cosby and loved it you know what i
mean yeah i mean i i wonder about that
it's a little hero worship too right
like you like how much of it is
you're supposed to love it how much of
it you love it because it's great
yeah i guess i mean if they here
worshipped him yeah
before he got oh yeah arrested everybody
hero worshipped him
i didn't he didn't i never liked it i
didn't like his act that much i mean i
thought he was
one time i uh i did a big benefit a big
carnegie hall show it was after nine
right after 9 11 and cosby was on
and it was a it was it's an interesting
night for two years but one of them is
we he asked to meet me after my set he
was here worshipping me joe in my
opinion but wow
he brought me up because he wanted to
meet me because i said so i go up and i
brought my girlfriend at the time
very you know pretty and
he i walked in with her and she had a
certain look that i could and
you know like very exotic looking too
and
you know dressed up and cosby was there
in
sweatpants smoking a cigar in carnegie
hall which you know
only certain people get away with she's
in some dressing room connie with a
cigar
and he's talked to me for 20 minutes he
looked at me
for about eight seconds of the 20 he was
literally
looking but he made it a joke but it was
dead serious
but he was looking at her while he was
talking to me the whole time
and we're all like laughing like he's in
on the joke but it was so
like she thought it was so weird but the
same night tom popper was there with his
wife cynthia
and bill clinton was there too it was
like a big you know right after 9 11.
and clinton was shot he walked around
the room he just he was so smart you
know
everything they say about him but then
he starts talking to tom papa
he starts flirting with cynthia right in
front of everybody and we're all
laughing
but he's like hey i love it
it was one of those nights fascinating
in retrospect right it was a me too
benefit in retrospect i remember i
called
bill cosby a douchebag on your show when
i was on tough crowd
because he was ahead of the time he was
uh being
interviewed by wanda sykes right
and wanda was interviewing him and he
starts chastising her for the way she's
talking
that's right and he had sunglasses on i
go that guy's a [ __ ] douchebag
that's true and that's great and i
remember thinking like geez who the [ __ ]
am i
called bill cosby a douchebag i mean
this is like yes
i mean when was tough crowd what year am
i talking about how can you take down
2004 yeah and i was like he's a [ __ ]
douchebag
that's hilarious i remember that when he
was like yeah you guys were amazing yeah
she was just having fun
yes and talking to him she was just
trying to be funny
and uh he chastised her for the way she
was speaking
it was crazy it was like it was real
weird like who the [ __ ] are you to tell
her how to talk especially on tv
especially everybody loves wanda yeah
like she's walking around the crowd
yeah and she's just working she's a
comic yes
it wasn't nothing she did was offensive
it was just
her talking and i remember being on the
show and then i remember leaving going
jesus
called bill cosby a douchebag episodes
of the joe rogan experience are now
free on spotify that's right they're
free
from september 1st to december 1st
they're going to be available everywhere
but
after december 1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love